ci sono sei regole per diventare un
artista ricco e famoso numero uno fai
grande arte dove abita a new york ridi
big perché è una cosa nervosa spero
quando ridi vuol dire che sei nervoso
numero 3 frequenta il mondo dell'arte
quattro sì professionale 5 si
personaggio e numero 6 trovi altre
persone per lavorare per te
nessuno mi ha insegnato queste regole
ho imparato della guerra di fare una
carriera dall'arte mi sono accaduto
molte volte o danni sul mio corpo
avevo sangue della superficie del mio
corpo e poi dopo ho vinto e poi qualcuno
mi ha chiesto di fare un incontro tipo
questo a new york tanti anni fa e doveva
prepararmi ho guardato la mia vita la è
la mia carriera e ho fatto una lista
delle cose che funzionava ho concluso
che questi sta in regole sono seguiti da
quasi tutti artisti ricchi e famosi
quasi tutti 99 pulsanti
non posso spiegare quello 1 per cento
che non segue queste regole però
sicuramente dovete seguire almeno cinque
di questi regole qualche eccezione per
esempio damian hirst non abitava a new
york abita a londra il ricorso mosso ha
fatto un po di storia ed arte però ha
fatto tante mostre a new york anche tra
i trans avanguardia kia cookie e
clemente i tre p tre più famosi a enzo
cucchi non abitava a new york però ha
fatto una retrospettiva nel guggenheim e
andava lì spesso per fare mostre invece
sandro chia enzo cucchi sandro chia e
francesi francesco clemente abitava
molto tempo a new york e non è una
coincidenza che loro hanno una grande
carriera
ma questo discorso non vuol dire non è
solo per artisti perché si può usare
utilizzare queste regole per altri
carrier e per altre carriere non è
numero due
abita a new york necessariamente se vuoi
essere un attore forse meglio noli web
oppure se vuoi essere un cantante di
musica country forse nasce o oppure se
vuoi essere una guida turistica di roma
forse è meglio vivere a roma comunque de
dovete vivere dove ci sono le ho per te
unità
spiegando numero uno fa grande arte come
si fa grande arte prima devi fare
esattamente quello che anni fare con
molto entusiasmo e passione perché
entusiasmo contagioso
la gente vede se tu stai facendo quello
che il che ami loro si seggono fai tutto
che vuoi
però non lo dire che necessariamente
deve mostrare tutto che hai fatto in un
regala via un museo
puoi mostrare su sorso media per capire
quali sono più efficaci
dovrete comunicare con la sua arte fate
tanti sondaggi io quando ero uno
studente di arte al caos table chen sud
california vicino disneyland chino era
man ogni mattina quando sono andato
nella scuola di hartley a
le classi ricominciavano alle alle 9 per
un mio padre aveva un lavoro che
cominciavano alle 7 mi ha portato nella
sua macchina alla scuola e aveva due ore
per passare e ho fatto tanti mille
disegni ogni mattina erano tipo
scarabocchi e ho cominciato condividere
questi disegni anni e altri studenti e
insegnanti amici e amiche e loro hanno
dato a entra è stato molto energia mica
mi piace questo più di questo però apple
con questo sondaggi ha sviluppato mio
linguaggio universale quella figura di
kostabi la figura senza voto che
diventato con un linguaggio universale
questi erano i miei primi market survey
oggi faccio la stessa cosa usando
facebook
instagram ogni mattina mettere un nuovo
quadro disegni graham e facebook che
seguo subito i risultati è super chiaro
in un atto di mezz'ora che alcuni
disegni sono molto amati rispetto ad
altri non vedere che gli altri non vanno
bene però quello che sono meno efficaci
e comunicare con una massa non sarebbe
intelligente usare questo su un invito
di una mostra meglio mettere quello che
tutti amano creare una copertina di un
libro oppure per fare un quadro grande
forse quello non amato può funzionare
come un quadro piccolo dovette avere un
dialogo con il pubblico per fare il
grande arte dovete fare qualcosa che la
gente veramente vuole dentro casa
una cosa desiderabile è importante
chiedere tante domande consigli e
ascoltare perché ascoltare vale molto di
più di parlare spesso tranne adesso sto
parlando a un valore però al solito non
parlo così parlo così perché mi sono
stato chiesto di parlare così se io vado
che ne un'inaugurazione dia un'altra
artista e comincia a parlare così sarà
buttato fuori in due secondi perché
dicono tutti chi è questo nego la meno
che parla solo su se stesso ci sono
momenti quando devi parlare e altri
momenti molto di più quando devi
ascoltare sarebbe stato meglio se tutto
il mondo a ha capito questo perché il
primo errore che fanno quasi tutti gli
artisti nel mio campo d arte parlano
troppo ascoltano quasi niente
poi aiuta studiare il tecnica
io ho fatto scuola d arte ha dato tante
tecniche era già un aveva un sogno di
chi sa disegnare per marzo e dissi con
il primo speaker ha parlato di questo
volevo segnalare spyro non è però non
riuscivo però dopo scoperto la
vanguardia e avevo successo nel mondo
mondo dell'arte ho fatto una mostra
bello villas proprio stand rientrava è
detto che ampia che bella la tua lavoro
possiamo fare un graphic novo del siam e
standing offerto questo è a questo punto
non volevo fare più perché il mondo di
arte contemporanea sembrava più
divertente più facile i fumettisti
sembravano più come schiavi abitare a
new york importante numero due
perché dopo anni 40
new york ha sostituito parigi come il
centro di arte contemporanea
internazionalmente successo perché c'era
la guerra tutti gli artisti dovevano
scappare disastro a parigi e tanti sono
andati a new york europei e poi con
abstract express maison de kooning power
new york è diventato decisamente il
centro del mondo di arte contemporanea
ed è ancora alcuni dicono che grazie
all'internet cambiato tutto e non è
necessario stare a new york in un centro
d arte più puoi fare tutto c'è un
piccolo merita di questo per un moto
piccolo perché ci sono galleristi a new
york ci sono oltre 1500 gallerie a new
york ponentine anatomy ci andrà joan e
per questo perché funziona questa città
i collezionisti vanno lì per comprare il
contatto physical e con collezionisti
con mercanti con altri artisti e molto
importanti dal vivo e poi si può usare
l'internet per per fare i follower per
fare extra promozione però è
assolutamente essenziale a frequentare
il mondo dell'arte a new york che il
numero 3 io mi sono trasferito da new
york a 1.800 1982 è per un anno mezza o
pensavo che l'unica cosa che doveva fare
e fare
beh egiziani e bei quadri però non
funzionava ero sconosciuto poi ho capito
che forse meglio andare in qualche
inaugurazione il primo inaugurazione
dove sono andato era sul green street
passano nella grande galleria di leo
castelli che aveva un altro suv plouay
ho incontrato una persona una provetta
critica d'arte e lui mi è piaciuto e mi
ha presentato un altro 5 persone questi
cinque mi hanno presentato di un altro 5
cadauno in un arco di un'ora ho
conosciuto 25 protagonisti nella scena
di arti a new york e dopo
l'inaugurazione era super chiaro che
questa è la strada da prendere perché
tutti gli altri stavano già facendo
questo è poi una settimana dopo
uno di questi artisti che ho incontrato
mi ha invitato di essere partecipante di
una collettiva assoro è un altro una
settimana dopo in stage poi un'altra
sono e tanti altri
e dopo un arco di un anno ho vinto un
premio che si chiamava pro deflation
france per l'artista che era il più
mostre di tutti artisti a new york ha sì
personaggio come è di nuovo con sua
parrucca e il fatto che lui era famoso
per essere famoso salvador dalì con il
baffo stravagante a caravaggio chi ha
ucciso una persona e bangkok e tagliato
i capelli questi storie aiutano i
giornalisti scrivere su di te non è
basta fare grande alto e beve devi fare
il lavoro del giornalista
è diventato conosciuto per essere
l'artista che non dipinge il suo quadri
perché una batteria di collaboratori che
dipinse per è cominciato ricevere tanti
articoli pubblicità gratis per questo
scandalo situazione è un giorno mai
state traction pains mi hanno invitato
di essere un soggetto sul workshop e io
non istintivo meritato e poi avevo
l'idea di perché avevo solo sei o sette
collaboratori aveva l'idea di chiedere
tutti i miei amici di fare finto di
essere i miei collaboratori e loro tv
sono arrivati hanno visto 20 state
collaboratori principalmente tutto finta
però lo show andava alla grande ho
guadagnato molti soldi subito dopo che
grazie questo show e aveva i soli di
assumere veramente 27 dei collaboratori
comunque era un illusione che ho usato è
così nasce nato il titolo gli studi
perché mio fratello a miass un giorno ho
chiesto a mio fratello popstar come
possiamo titolare questo quadro e lui ha
detto ieri silvio berlusconi perché ti
ho visto usando questo illusione per
creare la tua nuova realtà e poi è
diventato il famoso disco comunque
stanno qui per aiutare tutti voi aiutare
il mondo questo è il mio obiettivo
principale e ci sono due nuove regole
offre il secchio ho detto
numero7
credi
credi nel testo e numero otto non
dimenticare i tuoi amici
io ho tanti amici in italia soprattutto
nelle marche abruzzo umbria e ogni tanto
forse dimentico un nome però non
dimenticherò mai il mulino bellissimo
cuore di italiani e anche a roma un
piatto di calcio pepe grazie
[Musica]
no